[Applause]
oh
absolutely so i then she sat him down
and then she said the entanglement [ __ ]
i had the entanglement august and will
was like entanglement
she's like yeah and then he said you
cheated essentially and she goes that's
what i said
no [ __ ] it's not at all what you said
yeah he said you had a relationship yeah
she said that's what i said no [ __ ]
that's not what you said at all this is
the fakest [ __ ] on the internet
whoa the fakest [ __ ] on the internet
you're on an entire platform
is being honest real talk helping other
people
and then she says in this thing i think
one thing she says that's a lie and we
have to fact check this but she said i
didn't talk to him for four years
i think he was on red table talk like a
year ago talking about addiction but
anyway
even if that's not true she says this
was very healing for me to go through
this and i learned a lot about myself
which first of all is if any guy said
that again it would be like get the [ __ ]
out of here you're just actually you
know i needed to heal by [ __ ] 23. yes
100 hey when i learned about me with
that 18 year old i was healing
i was learning about myself listen i got
my dick sucked right
in a bennigan's but i was healing when i
did that you have to understand when the
waitress was sucking my dick in the
bathroom of a bennigan's
it was healing for me the awesome
blossom sauce on my dick
had a medicative effect and babe the
meal was about 100
how much i'd tip on this [ __ ]
you already did bro but for real though
here's my point
your show's about honesty and healing if
this was healing for you you could have
very easily shared it
throughout this entire process of
filming this series what two years has
been on
and you had will on talking about
relationship difficulties before
but you never shared it why because you
always needed to be
put together perfect jada and you're not
you were [ __ ] phony
and if you were honest you would help a
lot more people but you ain't gonna [ __ ]
about helping people
you're a [ __ ] about looking perfect oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] and will too if it's an
open relationship
i'm gonna be honest i think she just
made him do that [ __ ] and he was like
all right let me give her a career to
shut her ass up yo mark says something
interesting once one time
about open relationships no i thought
this was really interesting
people always go when the when like a
famous guy and his wife have an open
relationship
right yeah people are always like nah
it's okay to have an open relationship
she's okay with it they have an open
relationship right no they have an open
relationship
and then mark goes once you think if he
was like hey we should not have an open
relationship anymore
she'd be like damn
[Laughter]
you don't want that yeah you know what
i'm saying you want now i don't know
about the smiths per se because
apparently from what i've heard they're
both out there just getting cracked and
cracking cheeks right like i think
will's doing him
we've been hearing that for 15 years
yeah will's doing him he just looks like
a cuck because we don't know about his
business
because he knows how to handle his side
pieces so is this the most
like the savviest move for him is to
come on and look like the good guy like
the most alpha move is actually like
all right let me come on let me do this
thing look like a good guy and then i'm
gonna go [ __ ] whoever yo
real talk attention
is currency now you missed the fourth of
july
everybody's talking about them that's
what they want if you did listen listen
there is maybe
some fundamental differences between a
smith family and a kardashian family but
we spoke about this a long time ago
with the kardashians coming for the
sorry the smith's coming for the
kardashians
they want to be the first family of the
internet or the first family of america
right and they're going about it
from what we see as like a way more in a
way more like positive direction right
it might be phony like you're saying but
at least it is if hey this show is about
healing let's get better
empowerment let's have this great family
dynamic let's do things that we need to
do to feed our soul etc right
they're like if you add in some like
oprah elements you know what i mean like
and that being said they wouldn't do it
in front of the camera they didn't want
attention for it
so they are monetizing this are they
monetizing the positivity behind it sure
at the end of the day who gives a [ __ ]
if you get more out of it that's fine
it is interesting to see though that
even through tragedy you will get matter
of fact you get even more clout and more
attention in tragedy
i wonder what happens next with them
when they go oh we were really popping
when there was some drama
we're not really popping when we're
getting people over their pill addiction
but when we got some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
going on the family
everybody was watching hey jayden you
might want to go public about that
little drug addiction you got hey willow
you might want to go public about that
older boyfriend you got i wonder if they
tasted are these real rumors no no i'm
making things up like i wonder if they
get a little
taste of the what is it the dark side
the dark force
taste that kardashian fame right but
like you know star wars had like the
force
yeah the dark side the dark side like
you're like oh that's just tasty like
the black spider man outfit you're like
ooh this power feels good
right i wonder if they get a taste if
they start leaning in
but it makes sense like this was the
most viewed facebook
video i think of like all time like in
terms of like
velocity they're not going back these
say what you want about these people
and by these people i mean entertainers
but specifically the smith family
if you're in entertainment you have some
sort of addiction to attention
yeah you know what i mean ourselves
included we're in this
once you get that taste it takes unreal
discipline
to not lean into it yeah it's one of the
things i think that we're
we're actually exceptional at this if we
can to our own horn here
we know that we can have a porn star on
this show every single week and it's
gonna do
insane views but we have and we
specifically talk about the things we
want to talk about and how we want to
talk about them we shun
money if it doesn't go against it we
really kept our integrity
it's hard for [ __ ] to do that
it's hard to do
especially when your movies are flopping
will hasn't had a hit in a
minute bro it's been a long ass i don't
think jada ever had a hit i don't even
know
what she does jay's hit was will jay's
hit was will
real tough she's had a lot of classic
movies ain't nobody watch
wu except me i mean and only for tommy
davison
[Music]
she's she's had movies but she hasn't
had a hair what do you love low down
dirty shame she hasn't had like a huge
hit
recently recently bro my homie said it
well if it wasn't for real you would
just be that girl who's on a different
world for a couple of seasons
wow i don't think so what was she doing
before that i don't think so
[ __ ] that's her credit as well she was
in madagascar
after will oh are we talking about only
after will just
talk before will what was her hit what
year was that where she got what will
late 90s okay so everything prior to 98
was a different world low down dirty
shame the nutty professor
the nutty professor i think that was
after will too i think oh no maybe it
was before i mentioned society there's
no question
like having an incredibly powerful and
famous husband is going to help you with
your career yeah
right hillary clinton that being said
that like you could also do things that
are
great and she did things prior to him
etc the thing is are they going to be
able to take a taste of this
and turn it down i i don't know i'm not
sure
i think so
to an extent i think uh my
interpretation of this is that they just
love to control the narrative the reason
why they came to the table
is because the narrative was getting out
of their hands like they're nice
because they lied about it yeah they
lied about the narrative though yeah but
i hear but i hear what you're saying i
think you're on it keep it up
right yeah because we've never really
seen will do this
will doesn't have to address any rumors
about him he's always just stated he's
calling will gay for [ __ ] decades
never addressed it yeah but this one is
like yo
okay now it's affecting home it's
affecting uh the kids most likely and
[ __ ] like that like
and there's so much attention and [ __ ]
is a little dry right now yeah we can
spin this in a way where we come out on
top it's a learning
what's it called like i'm learning
moment or something
whereas i'm pretty sure she got the
[ __ ] whoever
tristan thompson cheated on with the
jordan whatever she got that [ __ ] on
faster and she put out her own things
do you think it affects movie rules for
him if he looks like a [ __ ]
if he looks like he's like simping for
jada it's interesting he can't be a
leading man
like you know how they like black ball
like gay dudes from being leading men
yep
like i don't think so because at the end
of the day people are still clapping
like oh he's
he did the right thing like jada
made this little mishap and he came to
the table as a man and like
there was one line where will said i'ma
get you back and jado was like you did
you did plenty oh like that's his way of
saving his manhood within the crap you
watch
the whole thing it's 12 minutes 12
minutes
i watched the whole long one i'm gay
there's way
40 minutes i already watched one i can't
get 12 more to refute the 40 minutes
there's way more to this story like way
more to the story because
in this in the beginning they talk about
like oh we were at the point of not
not even knowing if we were going to
speak again and the public
the republican spin is we were separated
august didn't ask for your permission
because he didn't need your permission
we were separated that's her
i did okay so august lied about
permission so
yeah which is he would he would tell the
truth about the affair but lie about
getting permission that's
weird to me no but then she addressed
that too because she said she said
um so when they first i guess started to
[ __ ] or whatever the case was
will wasn't even in the picture but then
will started to come back into the
picture
so they had a talk just to like you know
like
we're cool whatever the case is because
she did address that like
she can see how he might have took it as
asking for permission
but it was really just on some let's
just clear the air so [ __ ] isn't weird
around here
i don't believe that either nobody asked
jayden jaden
jaden ask his permission yo
i actually don't go smoking i believe um
i believe everything august said
really yeah yeah why would he lie
outside of promoting the album
i mean that's a big reason why what's
weird is that i haven't heard a single
song off this [ __ ] house has anyone
listened to album
no is that [ __ ] good i don't know they
redirected i mean he must have wrote
written a song you got to give her some
bars he did yeah here's what i would say
though
from what i thought thought my
perception of august elcena
is i would see his name and i'll be like
yo i think this guy puts out good music
i remember liking some of it before yeah
but he hadn't cracked off why does
nobody know who he is
now we know who he is yeah this seemed
like the missing element was attention
and then here you go he got imagine
you're coming out
of the fame was [ __ ] a 50 year old
woman
it's also will smith's wife
so that's why it's like he there's
plenty of points for that
as will's wife like you took will
smith's wife well he didn't take will
smith's wife let's that's what the
narrative says
will smith and his wife they were broken
up
and then she started dating him i think
that part i don't know if that part is
true i think
my interpretation of what he said the
first time is we have they have an open
relationship
will was cool with it and then they the
smiths were like all right how do we
spin this we don't want this open
relationship [ __ ] out to be public
that's right how do we spin this that's
right
either that or she cheated while they
were separated and she filed for that
how much how much do you think
this had to do with both of her kids now
being out of the house having their own
independent lives and like being adults
and her wanting to like nurture and take
care of something like empty nest
syndrome i think is called